I'm Leah belletto and this is the Sky
News Daily
it's Tuesday evening we're back outside
the high court in London because today
is the day Prince Harry started giving
evidence in his case against the Mirror
newspaper group it's the first time in
130 years that a royal has appeared in
court and it's fair to say it's been
pretty explosive
we've also had his full witness
statement more than 50 pages of it in it
he describes the behavior of the Tabloid
press towards him as utterly vile and he
blamed them for inciting hatred and
casting him as a thicker and a Playboy
now the court Rose for the day a little
while ago and the streets outside where
we are right now is well it's the
quietest it's been all day we've managed
to grab some time though with our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock thanks so
much for joining us it's been quite a
day hasn't it today oh my God it's been
completely Bonkers okay let's let's just
boil this down a little bit we have
Prince Harry who is the son of the king
coming to testify at the high court this
just doesn't happen we've been talking
Emily the last time it happened was back
in 1891 Edward VII then Prince of Wales
came in testified for 20 minutes and
then went off again Harry has had a
whole day of cross-examination and it
has been rigorous we always knew it was
going to be that is the point of
cross-examination but it has been an
intense experience for him and I do
think that he has kept his cool
throughout the day and if the mirror
Barrister was hoping to go to him to
sort of prod him into saying something
he perhaps didn't want to say he didn't
quite achieve that well this is the
thing isn't it because we have this
lengthy witness statement you're holding
it
I mean it was his chance to put his side
of the story out there wasn't it Laura
yeah I mean come on there'll be a lot of
people who said hey we've heard Harry's
side of the story repeatedly haven't we
we've had a Netflix docu-series we've
had a memoir we've had interviews Galore
but I think what this does which perhaps
we haven't heard from Harry all 55 pages
of it feels more like a Manifesto
because remember there is a purpose to
Harry coming here today he could have
settled we know he's chosen not to but
what he wants to do and what he calls
his life's work and this is very much
part of this life's work this is perhaps
chapter one it is make some real change
he wants to bring about change so he is
setting out his stall here you've got
the 33 articles that he's talking about
they are drawn from thousands and
thousands these are the most compelling
ones basically all instances where he
says his private information bits about
his private live hacked into and that
resulted in the article you know by
phone hacking by blagging of information
private investigators all of that kind
of stuff he's got to go through all of
those with what we've been hearing today
but there is as at the end you get more
of a sense of where where he's going
with this he says the British people
deserve to know what was going on that
is what he wants to achieve here so
aside from what we've heard he obviously
wants a win it's not about the money for
him he he wants to to bring about some
change to hold those he believes are
completely responsible but he has a hard
job doesn't he because he has to prove
that those journalists use unlawful
methods to gather that information to
publish those stories how tough is that
yeah it is tough so look let's take a
story for example Beach Bum Harry that
was about his Gap year in 2003 there
were some bits of information in that
story that Harry wasn't very happy about
the mirror group said well okay but hang
on we weren't the only ones publishing
this story but there were statements
coming out of the palace saying that
things were going a bit wrong you
weren't liking the kind of constant
press popping up and people taking your
photo Etc it wasn't just us there were
other articles we were getting our
information from legitimate sources and
Harry had to try and prove that no you
were getting it illegally and that was
the tricky thing I think in some of
these instances I think there was a
Smoking Gun moment when he was talking
about flight information so Chelsea
Davey his ex-girlfriend features in more
than a third of these articles his
relationship then which ended up you
know they split up because she decided
Royal life wasn't for her because of
this amount of press intrusion and the
fact that his private flight information
popped up in an article he says look
this is a red flag security my travel
arrangements are never mentioned about I
don't talk about them because it is kind
of sensitive information so that was the
moment where I kind of thought the
mirror Barrister was more on the back
foot when it came to his sort of
questioning well we can get our stories
from other sources if you like so this
witness statement 55 pages long Sky
journalists have spent the day kind of
picking out big moments from that can we
go through some of those because at one
point Prince Harry he really does hold
the Tabloid press responsible for a lot
of the difficulties I suppose in his
life and in particular he points the
thing directly at Pierce Morgan who was
editor of the mirror back then and he
mentions him by name multiple times what
did you make of that yeah he does Harry
has said all along that he believes that
it wasn't just the journalists who were
engaging the the blagging methods
there's these unlawful activities but it
was the editors who knew it was going on
and in some cases not just knowing it
was going on but commissioning it asking
for it to happen these are the editors
including Piers Morgan that he thinks
should be here giving evidence he these
are the editors he wants held to account
and Piers Morgan love gives you one
example basically he says the reason he
feels Megan's been vilified and
demonized so much is because Harry's
bringing this case he says that him and
Megan have been subjected to a barrage
of horrific personal tax and
intimidation from Piers Morgan as a
consequence of him bringing the mirror
group claim so he's leveling some pretty
big accusations at Pierce Morgan who's
always denied any knowledge that this
was going
the other one Laura Prince Harry talking
about actually how all relationships in
his life were affected by this press
intrusion this unlawful Gathering um it
caused tensions between relationship
with friends and he thought actually
they're leaking stories about him
um so just setting up the stage that
every part of his life from a young boy
a teenager right through to his
professional life was hacked yeah he
said nothing was off limits didn't he I
mean yesterday we heard how nothing was
sacrosancter out of bounds but I feel
that despite the fact he had this huge
privilege of growing up a prince in
palaces and the like he had nothing when
it came to privacy that there was this
real blurring of the line when it came
to what was in the public interest and
what people were interested in and he
said the papers crossed those lines
basically by kind of feasting on
negative stories about him which people
wanted to read and it fueled that kind
of situation where the Press would then
do everything they could to try and get
more information because those were the
stories that sold their papers the other
one that will stand out for me was the
fact that he was worried that he'd get
booted out of Eaton because of stories
about drug taking you know as a young
boy that would have been tough yeah
definitely the drug taking was a big
issue or a bit a bit one of the big
stories that came up today a lot about
his time at Eden I mean there was this
agreement wasn't there when both William
and Harry were eaten that they would be
left to kind of have a childhood and
grow up as teenagers at secondary school
and there's a sense isn't there that
that just didn't happen and we heard a
story about Harry's back injury so we
couldn't play rugby and the like but he
wouldn't he said have given out
information as doctor had told him he
didn't want you know to talk about his
friends with those sorts of details and
he certainly didn't want his friends to
view him negatively and the this was the
kind of intrusion that was constantly
constantly going on but when he was
cross-examined by the mirror's lawyer
Andrew Green QC who actually he has a
bit of a reputation apparently he's
known as the Beast by his colleagues um
he had these three lines of attack that
I'd really love to go through
um so the first one being the fact that
actually many of the articles that were
published Harry
wouldn't have read or didn't read
because he was very young so that was
the first line of attack what did you
make of that well I think what he's
trying to say was if you didn't read the
article how did it cause you any
distress basically so was it really
invading your privacy because you didn't
know about it and now he's saying well
actually I might not have been reading
about it but people I know did when it
comes to school all my mates were
reading about these articles and they
were judging me about them and even at
Sandhurst and the like he's sort of said
he'd walk into a room and kind of what
were people going to think of me they
sort of had a pre-judgment when it came
to him because of all the stuff that had
been written about him and then the
second line of attack was that actually
this information well it was already out
there other newspapers published it and
so how could it really have affected you
if it was there see that's the tricky
one isn't it because on the one hand you
could say well it's it's popped up in
this evening standard or in the
telegraph The Daily Mail what have you
but I think what Harry's team have been
trying to prove that even when other
newspapers had stories so Harry dressing
up as a Nazi the classic there was a
story in the sun wasn't it
either way what the mirror group would
then do is try and use this illegal kind
of information gathering to get their
own lines on the stories so it might
have popped up somewhere else but was it
using extra information extra details
that there's only one way they could
have got their hands on and it's not a
lawful way yeah and then the third line
of attack is saying actually Prince
Harry you were just embarrassed by the
fact that stories about alleged drug
taking had taken place not the methods
used
yeah I mean you know I think Harry will
be the first to admit he's done a lot of
stuff in his childhood that he isn't
proud of I mean the drug taking is a
classic example there he's spoken about
it adding for an item in interviews in
in spare all the drugs he's taken hasn't
he and you know he's always known that
there'll be a huge amount of interest in
what he gets up to but again it comes
back to that point you know it is
illegal obviously the drugs he was
taking but he had this extra pressure
this extra scrutiny on him because of
his position and there was nothing he
could ever do without someone finding
out
and so with that in mind then Laura what
did you make of his overall demeanor in
court because there were a few you know
Court etiquette issues that happened but
did you think he was in control yeah I
think what could have happened today
didn't happen and that's Harry got
rattled he got riled he exploded he went
down some tricky rabbit you know dug
himself all sorts of holes he I think
towards the end seemed a bit more in
control he seemed measured he seemed
quite calm and pretty confident I think
I mean he was sort of talking at one
point directly to the judge which
doesn't happen you know you don't do
that but I think that will be you know
just because he's in a weird situation
and but I think you have to remember
that he is on his own in there it is
packed but he is on his own his legal
team won't be talking to him now and
until he stops giving evidence that will
be the case so they can just sit there
and watch and there's nothing they can
do the words that are coming out of
Harry's mouth now are his words alone
but we're not used to members of family
having opinions because he he did at one
point say that you know the press and
the government a rock bottom that was
quite I I found that quite interesting
that yeah it's always been tricky hasn't
it the opinion the political how
political the members the royal family
get because the king you know is
well-known critic and outspoken on
several issues and many have said these
cross lines in the past but yeah Harry
kind of was quite explicit with that
talking about the government hitting
rock bottom but Harry says what he wants
to say doesn't he he always has to learn
he wouldn't get William saying that you
wouldn't get William in court you know
because he settled in he in another case
but yeah Harry is a is a different
kettle of fish when it comes to what the
Royals do and the Royals I'm sure will
be watching because it's not just Harry
at State here it's mentioning the late
Queen Elizabeth II and the fact that she
sent a private secretary on his break in
Australia King Charles II so they will
be watching with vested interests
obviously yeah I mean we said yesterday
didn't we the king conveniently isn't in
the UK at the moment he's in
Transylvania
and as far away from this as possible
bird watching whatever he does painting
um they will be informed and updated
without doubt in terms of what it here I
think probably with the royal family
there was always a sense Harry's going
to do this anyway there's nothing we can
do William will not be happy about kind
of these private conversations you know
being talked about again being dragged
up again particularly given the fact
that the brothers have had such a
falling out in in the past and it would
be difficult for Chelsea Davey too this
is you know quite a long time ago for
her she's married has had a baby you
know she has a whole new life now and
you know it'll be hard for her having
all this dragged up it probably wasn't
much fun for her back in the day either
so lastly can you talk me through what
we are expecting on Wednesday and then
actually when we hear back from from the
judge on any kind of verdict uh yeah
firstly well Wednesday we'll see more of
the same basically so another half a day
of cross-examination for Harry by the
mirror group Barrister so that will
cover the other half of the 33 articles
and then sort of Harry's sort of summing
up I guess he'll try and get across
um the bigger mission in this do not
expect any kind of ruling anytime soon
the judge will be really going through
everything because you know you've got
senior Royal here making some pretty big
accusations and if he finds in favor of
Harry or doesn't find in favor of me
essentially accusing Harry of not
telling the truth in some ways isn't it
so he's gonna have to weigh it all up so
in terms of what he finds it will be I
wouldn't even thought it would be weeks
it'll be months before we find out yeah
well thank you so much for your time
Laura I know you're a busy woman but we
appreciate your time on the podcast
thank you no problem thank you
my thanks to Laura and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Leah balletto this episode was produced
by Rosie Gillett with Sydney peed our
editor was Paul stamworth and just to
let you know there's a special Sky News
program on TV at nine o'clock each
evening reflecting on the day's Court
proceedings so if you're listening after
they've played that out you can watch it
back on our mobile app and YouTube
channel